surveillance video from Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School shows how a
sheriff's deputy failed to go after the
gunman in last month's deadly shooting
it's got Petersen who was assigned to
the school is seen say staying outside
while the gunman killed 17 people
Adriana Diaz he's at the school in
parkland Florida
Adriana good morning good morning the
Sheriff's Office released 27 minutes of
surveillance videos that came from four
cameras of the roughly 70 security
cameras here at the school they didn't
release any videos that showed the
shooter just the ones that focus on what
Scott Peterson did as chaos unfolded
less than a minute after law enforcement
says the shooting began surveillance
video shows Scott Peterson the only
armed school resource officer assigned
to protect students never confronting
the gunman outside the school's
administration building away from where
the gunfire was unfolding Peterson is
seen walking down a corridor while
speaking on his radio seconds later he
begins running and sped in a golf cart
toward the freshmen building about 30
seconds later Peterson took a position
along a building across from the one
where the gunman was carrying out the
deadly rampage 911 calls revealed the
terror inside outside Peterson radios
dispatch but during the six minute
shooting he's never seen entering
building 12 which is just at a view to
the left of the pavement even after
acknowledging the disturbance was inside
partially obstructed by a pole Peterson
appears to remain at the same location
for about 20 minutes after law
enforcement says the shooter left the
building
last month Broward County Sheriff Scott
Israel said this when asked what
Peterson should have done went in
addressed the killer killed the killer
the sheriff said he was sick to his
stomach when he saw Peterson in the
videos now Peterson a decorated 32-year
veteran said he didn't go in because he
thought the shooting was
outside Peterson and his lawyer didn't
respond to our request for comment about
the videos Peterson was suspended and
then retired but is still under
investigation
that video is very tough to watch thank
you very much Adriana